deux
pourquoi ne pas sortir et me parler
Je suis touché par le Seigneur alors il m'a dit
J'ai demandé au père Garcia de venir avec moi
le directeur spirituel
a beaucoup d'expérience dans des situations
de crise est un homme très préparé oui
eux-mêmes
nous avons une belle vie
nous menons une vie sainte
soeur, toi et moi savons pourquoi
les frères sont là
Je vois la célébration de la pénitence ce que je
J'ai besoin de savoir s'ils sont
conscients de la raison pour laquelle ils sont ici
l'église se lave les mains et nous
nous restons les boucs émissaires
nous allons devoir enlever cette petite maison
Dieu n'est pas là, c'est à propos de ça, c'est un
prison
J'ai celui-ci ici, je vais appeler
à la télévision et je vais raconter tout ça
Avez-vous déjà pensé que vous êtes un
délinquant ou que vous
en ce moment pour toi l'église
c'est moi
cette nuit
mais profitez-en